Ich bin schon seit 2 Stunden wach, also ich muss nicht unbedingt aufwachen, wobei wirklich
schwach bin ich auch nicht, 0w, 0w ist immer noch größer, keckw, eindeutig, kann ich
was alle an keckw finden. Gibt es eigentlich beim steam sale, ist doch
irgendwie gerade wieder winter, winter sale oder so, oder ist es schon vorbei, ich meine
ist eh nichts dabei was ich mir kaufen werde, also insofern, moin ktg, gris, kauf mir eh
nix bei steam, es gibt so viel bullshit bei steam mittlerweile, dass in dem mehr von bullshit
findest du kaum noch irgendwie gescheite Sachen, steam ist mittlerweile 90% shit, sag
den dazu, der typ hat snake auf seine weihnachtsbaum programmiert, wieso du hier apple werbung
kriegst, er musste twitch fragen, oder besser gesagt deine viewing history musste fragen,
scheinend bist du apple fan, oder zumindest interessiert an apple, die wissen das besser
als du, aber das ist doch hier, das ist doch wirklich next level poc oder, der typ mit
seine weihnachtsbaum, wo man snake mit dem ps4 controller spielen kann, moin was hältst
du von intern nooks, ist doch nicht schlecht, allerdings habe ich bis jetzt noch kein anwendungsgebiet
dafür gefunden wo ich einen gebraucht hätte oder gewollt hätte, also coole sache ist das
ja, leider nur in rot, das wäre natürlich cool, was halt richtig cool ist, dass du oben
rausfahren kannst und unten wieder reinkommst, das wäre natürlich cooler, wenn er das so
mit rgbs gemacht hätte, also garantiert irgendwelche rgb leds, dass es nicht nur rot wäre, sondern
dass man die farbe wechseln würde, schneller, langsamer, aber cool ist es, muss man sagen,
ich meine nicht, dass es was bringt, aber es geht, das ist das wichtigste, ich finde
das schon nice, ich will lieber bedcompany 3, ja top vergleich, snake auf dem weihnachtsbaum
oder bedcompany 3, weil das ja auch so sachen sind, die man so direkt miteinander vergleichen
muss, ich hätte gerne lieber bedcompany 3 gehabt als die letzten zwei battlefield main
games, james ryan, guck dir einfach das max reveal aus der picking super an oder guck dir
irgendwelche videos, es gab mittlerweile einige videos wo ich drin rumgesprungen bin, auf gamescom
videos bin ich drin rumgesprungen, das hat bloß keiner gecheckt, in battlefield videos
bin ich schon drin rumgesprungen, das hat bloß keiner kapiert, ich traue mich gar nicht
auf die reddit frontpage zu gucken, ich weiß gar nicht warum ich die aufgemacht habe, ich
glaube, nee war nichts schlimmes, aber irgendwie die reddit frontpage ist immer schwierig im
stream zu zeigen, aber weiß man nie so genau was da auf einmal drauf ist, soll ich spielen
jetzt oder nee nicht jetzt, nachher mal, spielen wir mal hier, das habe ich vorhin auf dem handy
gefunden, guess the programming language, kriegst du ein hello world snippet, musst raten was
für eine programmiersprache ist, das ist wirklich schwierig, was die sollten, battlefield 5 beenden
und sich hauptsächlich auf battlefield 6 basieren, die sollten vor allem ein gescheites
neues battlefield machen, eigentlich ist mir vollkommen wurscht wie das ganze heißt, battlefield
5 ist ja mittlerweile angeblich ganz ok, wobei es der letzte patch wohl wieder richtig verkackt
haben muss, hören sagen, ich spiele das ja selbst nicht, dann gucken wir ein bisschen
mario kart, dann gucken wir ein bisschen youtube, die witcher serie scheint schwer angesagt,
ich habe immer noch kein netflix account geholt, ich überlege mal ob ich wirklich mal ein
netflix probe abo mache um die witcher serie anzugucken, interessiert mich jetzt ein 6600k,
das ist ja outdated, overrated, jebaited, sag mal leute, ernstes fragen, bin ich der
einzige der sich irgendwie alexi bex hier nicht angucken kann, ich verstehe überhaupt
nicht was einem diese videos geben, der kann halt glaub ich nicht wirklich ahnung von technik,
die art und weise wie die videos gemacht werden ist übelst überdreht und nervig, ich kann
mir das nicht angucken, ich weiß nicht warum man sich das anguckt, aber gut, je nimmt das
sein, das sagen genauso viele über meine videos wahrscheinlich, einer mag es der spaßte,
haben sie auch recht, lul weh, relaxin nintendo music, oh das ist gut, komm wir hören uns
lieber relaxin nintendo music an als wub wub wub, ah yes, excellent piano, excellent, was
hamsen da drinnen, ach komm, wir gucken mal was, wie viele wub wub wub mixe, mixe, wie
wir hier einen vollen kriegen, mixe, mixe, where did sound cards go, ganz einfach, auf
mainboard, als wären die weg, was denn, so hässliche erweiterungs pc karten hat kein
mensch mehr, wozu auch, so ein bissl digital analog konverter und schlechte audio ausgänge
kann man da auf mainboard machen, daniel lul, 6 monate, mieser abo feiner, bonka tos, das
sass nicht so laut, danke schön, pock, so bad guys of 2000, was the worst cpu and gpu
purchases of 2000, weiß nicht ob das so interessant ist, ich kann mal kurz drüber skippen, diablo
4 juckt mich überhaupt nicht, ganz ehrlich, wenn ich wieder mal in hack and slay spielen
möchte, dann würde ich wieder pass of exile spielen, diablo ist bei mir vorbei, forgotten
battle royale game, ist das h1 z1, ach nee, das ist firestorm, was kein mensch mehr spielt,
warte mal, twitch, firestorm, ach moment, nee, nee, das hieß gar nicht firestorm, wie
hieß das, doch oder, hieß doch firestorm, das ist gar keine eigene kategorie, oh, der
meist geschaute Battlefield kanal h1 z1, games ist aber voll anges 17500 will ich sagen,
leute haben sich das game gekauft, spielen tut es anscheinend keiner mehr, man kann zwar
nicht immer direkt aus der beliebtheit auf twitch ableiten, wie beliebt ein game ist,
Aber es hängt auf jeden Fall zusammen, es hängt 100% zusammen, in der Regel sind Spiele
die gut laufen, auch Spiele die viel auf Twitch geguckt werden und umgedreht.
Wie kann man die gar nicht spenden? Du kannst mich einfach abonnieren auf Twitch, wenn du was spenden willst, du kannst auch einfach über mein Refleek bei Amazon irgendwas einkaufen oder einfach nichts machen und zukommen.
Alles umsonst, ich mach ja auch nichts, ich sitz da und guck ein bisschen Zeug ab.
Dani Lul, dich hatte ich schon, 6 Monate hier, excellent, big brain sub.
So, wir, alter ich hab hier irgendwas im Hals, kostenloses Entertainment, never sub, never subscribe, free WLAN, stolen laptop, free entertainment.
Leute, ihr könnt, wenn ihr schon copypasten wollt, dann müsst ihr richtig copypasten.
Ja, dener braucht ihr, dener braucht ihr, never sub, never donated, adblock on, stolen laptop, neighbors wifi, free entertainment, wenn schon dann richtig.
Wenn schon copypasten, dann richtig.
Wisst ihr was das Schlimme ist, mittlerweile trau ich mich gar nicht mehr bei Google, wenn man irgendwas Twitch related ist, wenn man irgendwas mit Bezug auf Twitch in Google eingibt, trau ich mich mittlerweile gar nicht mehr auf die Bildersuche zu gehen.
Weil es gibt mittlerweile so viel leicht begleitete Damen auf Twitch und die nicht nur, muss man dazu sagen, die nicht nur auf Twitch aktiv sind, sondern nur auf anderen Plattformen.
Wenn du auf Bildersuche klickst, kann das durchaus sein, dass du hier Monkertos Probleme kriegst.
Da muss man aufpassen.
Und wisst ihr an was mich das erinnert, dieses Geflöte, könnt ihr euch noch an das Geflöte von Ubisoft erinnern?
Der Flöten Typ war ja bei Ubisoft.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr für welches Game das war, für was für ein Game war das eigentlich nochmal.
Warte mal.
War das hier der Flöten Typ?
Ja hier.
Und es ging halt irgendwie drei Minuten oder so.
Und es ging halt ewig, ja.
Ist das eigentlich mittlerweile raus?
Der Flöten Typ war schon geil.
Game Trailer gucken wir an Sylvester wieder an, was 2020 so rauskommt.
Ok, das ist noch nicht released, alles klar.
Ich verwende fast nur noch DuckDuckGo, ich verwende kaum noch Google.
Der Name ist schon absolut Jebait.
Das Ding hier, mir ist das vollkommen egal.
Das Adblock funktioniert auch nur halb, aber nicht Brave.
Brave habe ich auch lange benutzt.
Brave hat ein Problem, wofür ich eigentlich andere Browser verwende als Safari.
Nämlich Sachen, dass ich YouTube und Twitch im Hintergrund abspielen kann.
Und das ist der einzige Browser, den ich gefunden habe bisher für iOS.
Der aktuell noch, Opera Mini ist ja nicht mehr im App Store.
Der im Hintergrund Twitch und YouTube abspielen kann.
Es sieht übelst nach China...
Es sieht übelst nach China Jebait aus.
Ich würde mich da auch niemals mit irgendeinem...
Die Twitch App kann sowas, ja, aber die YouTube App kann sowas nicht.
Und die Twitch App hat Werbung, trotz Twitch Prime.
Das Schöne an dem Browser ist, auf Twitch funktioniert der Adblock.
Das heißt, man kriegt keine Werbung und kann im Hintergrund abspielen.
Und auf YouTube ist der Adblock ein bisschen kaputt.
Aber dafür funktioniert im Hintergrund abspielen, was die YouTube App nicht kann.
Das ist eigentlich ein ganz guter Kompromiss.
Ich würde mich da im Leben nicht mit irgendeinem Account anmelden.
Weil allein schon der Name sieht nach China...
Allein schon, weil das Ding Private Browser heißt.
Da kannst du dir vorausgehen, da ist überhaupt nichts private.
YouTube...
Was bringt mir denn APK auf einem iPhone?
Ja, du kannst YouTube Premium kaufen, aber YouTube Premium ist der Witz.
Ähm...
Ja, da überlegst...
Also, erstens mal.
Ich mein...
12 Euro!
Dafür krieg ich Netflix und Amazon Musik.
Oder...
Oder, wenn ich dafür...
Spotify und...
Da krieg ich zwei Abos dafür.
Ich mein, 12 Euro!
Und du kriegst dafür ja nichts!
Du kriegst YouTube...
Der Sebaro wieder!
Das ist mal klar!
Ja klar, wenn man es aus Indien für ein paar Euro kriegt, okay.
Ähm...
Aber du kriegst ja im Prinzip nichts dafür.
Gibt's eigentlich YouTube Red noch?
Oder ist das jetzt auch Premium, ne?
Also ich mein, du kriegst ja nichts dafür im Endeffekt.
Du kriegst Ad Free?
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Ähm...
Background Play, das ist der absolut lächerlichste Grund überhaupt.
Ja?
Das ist der...
Ja, aber Musik Premium hast du sonst nicht.
Du kannst auch downloaden und sowas.
Aber Background Play hier überhaupt anzupreisen, ist das lächerlichste überhaupt.
Weil, das einzige, was das sagt, dass die hier Background Play anpreisen ist,
wir haben ein absolutes Basic Feature genommen, was früher jede 0815 Kack App konnte,
haben es ausgebaut oder absichtlich nicht erneuert, sodass es funktioniert,
um es dann als Premium Feature anzupreisen.
Also das ist das absolut lächerlich, ja.
Ad Free kann ich verstehen, ich mein, ich muss irgendwie Geld verdienen, okay.
Aber Background Play hier anzupreisen ist lächerlich, ja.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich YouTube App nicht mehr verwenden will.
Downloads ist auch so ein Basic Feature, ja, was auch...
Nein, nein, nein, ich suche nicht nach O, Vlog.
Ist auch so ein Basic Feature, wo man sich denkt, was ist daran Premium?
Also das hier und das hier, die zwei Sachen, die hier angepriesen werden,
für 12 Euro im Monat sind absolute Basic Features,
die jede Player App besitzen sollte und die nicht bereitgestellt werden
und die nicht schwierig zu programmieren sind.
Also man soll 12 Euro für irgendwas bezahlen, was einer in 45 Minuten eingebaut hat.
Ja, ich weiß, unter Android ist das Ganze kein Problem.
Unter Android gibt es genug Varianten.
Aber es geht mir jetzt ja gerade ums iPhone.
Ich habe schon mal geguckt vor einer Weile, ob es nicht irgendwelche Squid-
oder Proxy-Extensions gibt, die Adblock machen.
Aber das ist halt wegen, weil das mittlerweile alles über SSL läuft, nicht so einfach.
Würde theoretisch, wahrscheinlich mit irgendwelchen selbstsignierten Zertifikaten
und dann in den Store rein, also in den Zertifikaten-Store rein,
aber gut funktionieren tut es auf jeden Fall nicht.
Ja, also das ist der Witz, 12 Euro. Was ist mit denen nicht richtig?
Du kriegst irgendwelche komischen YouTube-Exclusive-Serien,
wo ich noch nicht bei einer bisher das Verlangen verspürt habe, die mir anzugucken.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was es da alles gibt, aber alles, was mir bisher empfohlen wurde,
wollte ich definitiv nicht schauen und geschweige einen 12-Euro-Monat dafür ausgehen.
Außerdem eine Sache, die mir auch extrem auf den Sack geht bei der YouTube-App ist,
jedes Mal, wenn du die YouTube-App aufmachst, wirst du gefragt,
ob du nicht einen Monat kostenlos Trial machen willst. Jedes Mal.
Und das geht mir so auf den Sack. Ich will keinen Trial.
Jedes Mal muss ich sagen, nein, ich will keinen Trial.
Das ist Low-Brain von Google, von YouTube, von ABC, von Alphabet.
Ach, wie auch immer wäre das genau.
Über den Browser geht das nicht unter iOS.
Ja, das Schöne ist, dieser Browser, den ich da entdeckt habe,
der nach China-Billig-Browser aussieht, du kannst sogar den User-Agent ändern
auf andere Browser, dass er nicht mehr erkennt, dass du unter iOS unterwegs bist.
Sofern sie es am User-Agent festmachen.
Play in Background. Ich meine allein schon, dass es YouTube-Music gibt,
die man nicht im Background spielen kann, aber das ist ein scheiß Player.
Die wollten ja, ich habe irgendwo mal gelesen, dass Apple mit iOS 13
quasi halbzwangs einführen, dass alle Player über die normalen iOS-Schnittstellen
spielen müssen. Und da haben sich wohl so viele App-Hersteller
beschwert, so nach dem Motto, was, da kann man ja auf einmal im
Hintergrund abspielen, da muss ja keiner in unser Zeug gucken.
Dass sie dann gesagt haben, nee, machen wir doch nicht.
Also, kompletter, weiß nicht, also, nee, muss nicht sein.
Ihr sind genug Leute da, jetzt können wir mal ein Spielchen spielen,
und zwar spielen wir jetzt, ja, ich weiß, auf Herz 3.9, auf Android
ist es kein Problem, aber auf iOS ist es ein Problem.
Wir spielen jetzt mal Rat in die Programmiersprache.
Wir fangen mit was Einfachem an, okay? Wir fangen mit was Einfachem an
und dann machen wir was richtig Schwieriges.
Aber das ist, ich habe es vorhin mal kurz ausprobiert, und das ist
randomizes Quiz, also das kenne ich auch nicht.
Das ist, das ist, das ist schwierig. Das hier ist einfach.
Das ist einfach. Das ist einfach.
Seid ihr schon, seid ihr schon brain, big brain genug heute Morgen,
dass wir, dass wir sowas machen können, ja?
Sind nur 20 Fragen oder so, ist nicht viel.
Schafft das euer Gehirn heute Morgen schon.
Also Leute, was ist das für eine Sprache?
Wir haben zur Auswahl Swift, Java, C-Sharp, C++, was ist das?
Ha, der Chat kennt es wieder aus.
Jawohl, das ist C++, richtig, eindeutig.
Allein schon daran erkennt man es.
Alter, low brain.
Leute, macht doch kein Source Code als Bild.
Source Code als Bild.
Das erinnert mich mal an eine Sache bei uns.
Irgendjemand bei uns auf der Arbeit, ich sage jetzt den Namen nicht,
der fand es auch immer geil in unser Ticket-System,
Screenshots von irgendwelchen Excel-Tabellen rein zu pasten.
Dann pasten wir den Text rein, um gut ist.
Nee, ging nicht.
Alles C++, richtig, next.
Ähm, das da.
Wir haben zur Auswahl C-Sharp, Java, Javascript.
Was ist das hier?
Man erkennt es ziemlich gut, ja?
Man kann sich, so von der groben Struktur her kann man sagen,
ok, Javascript ist es auf keinen Fall.
C-Sharp von der Struktur her vielleicht, aber von den Klassen aufrufen
und den Namespaces und von dem String her, von der Kleinen eher nicht.
Also bleibt da nur noch Java, ne?
Bleibt Java, der Chat weiß Bescheid.
Next.
Ha, jetzt wird es schwieriger.
Wobei das auch noch relativ offensichtlich ist.
Was ist das?
Javascript, C-Sharp, PHP oder Swift?
Also wir können das ja mal ausschließen.
Äh, Javascript.
Ähm, Function ist schon mal Javascript,
aber diese ganzen Dollar-Geschichten
und hier Arrays, Slice und Gedöns sieht nicht nach Javascript aus.
C-Sharp, so kannst du in C-Sharp keine Funktion anlegen,
die passt von der Syntax hier hinten und vorne nicht.
Swift passt auch nicht, aber PHP passt ganz gut.
Ja, PHP, richtig.
Also allein schon hieran erkennt man, dass es PHP ist.
Implode, Erase, Slice, das ist so typische PHP-Stunner-Library-Crap.
Ähm, okay, PHP.
Next.
Was, das ist ein bisschen schwieriger schon.
Das ist ein bisschen schwieriger.
Nicht so verbreitet, aber die Auswahl macht es einfach.
Die Auswahl macht es einfach.
Weil, wenn wir mal anfangen, ist das, das könnte aus Metroid sein, ja.
17.
Nein, doch.
Ja.
Metroid Prime.
Koteln, richtig.
Weil, Javascript kann es nicht sein, passt nicht von der Syntax her.
C passt von der Syntax her auch nicht, bleibt bloß koteln.
Also, wenn die jetzt so ein paar andere Sachen zur Auswahl reingebracht hätten,
so nach dem Motto zum Vergleich irgendwie Rust, Go, keine Ahnung, irgendwie so,
dann könnte man vielleicht ein bisschen überlegen, aber hier ist ganz klar koteln.
Okay, next.
Das ist offensichtlich undefined.
So einen Crap gibt es nur in einer Sprache.
Was ist es, Leute?
Ja, richtig.
Chad weiß Bescheid.
Also, Javascript, was sonst?
Muss.
Muss das?
So was Igles kann doch Javascript sein.
Object Prototype, das ist eindeutig Javascript.
Okay, next.
Was haben wir hier?
Das ist ein bisschen schwieriger.
Aber wenn man es mal verwendet hat, ist es auch relativ offensichtlich, was es ist.
Fangen wir mal von unten an.
Koteln ist es auf keinen Fall.
Von der ganzen Syntax her und vom Aufbau her.
Scala hat viel zu wenig Klammern.
Scala wäre alles eine riesen Klammer.
Ruby passt die Syntax hinten und vorne nicht.
Bleibt nur Rust und ich weiß auch, dass es Rust ist.
Das ist Rust Pattern Matching.
Und auch hier der Return Typ mit dem Pfeil und dem String und dem Name, Doppelpunkt, Typ.
Das ist eindeutig Rust.
Next.
So.
Ja.
Da wird es ein bisschen komplizierter.
Aber es ist auch durch die Auswahl relativ easy.
F-Sharp, sonderlich funktional sieht das Ganze nicht aus.
Swift passt von der Syntax her nicht.
Das heißt, es ist noch die Auswahl Ruby oder Pearl.
Für Pearl ist es nicht kryptisch genug.
Und eine typische Sache bei Ruby ist hier diese Schleife.
B, H, X, bla, bla, A, H, Print und Funktionen hier ohne Klammern.
Das sieht typisch Ruby-mäßig aus.
Deswegen ist das Ruby.
Oder sagt ihr was anderes?
Aber das ist definitiv Ruby.
Warum Ruby ist eine tolle Sprache?
Huge, big brain language.
Vergibt es eigentlich noch Leute, die Ruby on Rails verwenden?
Das war ja mal vor 15 bis 10 Jahren der heiße Shit, was Web-Frameworks angeht.
Next.
Was ist das?
Das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen schwieriger.
Da sage ich jetzt mal nichts.
Durch die Auswahl ist es relativ easy.
Eigentlich relativ einfach, aber da sage ich mal nichts.
Was ist das?
Richtig, Swift.
Chat weiß Bescheid.
Das ist Swift.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich bin da auch nur drauf gekommen.
Durch Ausschlussverfahren.
Ich habe gesagt, C-Sharp kann es nicht sein, Java kann es nicht sein.
Und wie PHP sieht das Ganze auch nicht aus.
Deswegen bin ich auch nur auf Swift gekommen.
Und durch diese Self-Geschichte.
Ich habe mal irgendwo gelesen, dass sie in Swift anstatt This Self verwenden.
Aber es war Ausschlussverfahren zu Swift.
Richtig gewusst habe ich es auch nicht.
Okay, das ist einfach.
Es ist alt auf jeden Fall.
Also überlegen wir mal.
Sieht es aus wie JavaScript?
Ne.
Definitiv sieht es nicht aus wie JavaScript.
Sieht es aus wie Visual Basic?
Ne.
Sieht es auch nicht aus wie Visual Basic.
Kann ja nur Fortran sein.
So.
Das ist eine der ehemaligen Big Brain Languages.
Aber heute eher PHP.
Next.
Ja.
Was ist das?
Da sage ich jetzt auch nichts zu.
Durch das Ausschlussverfahren ist es eigentlich ziemlich einfach.
Genau.
Also.
Ich meine, Assembler kann es auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht sein.
Das sieht einfach überhaupt nicht nach Assembler aus.
Das sieht nach deutlich höher als Assembler aus.
C kann es von der ganzen Syntax her und wie das mit den Argumenten aufgebaut ist.
Das kann eigentlich nur Go sein.
Es wäre viel interessanter gewesen.
Hätten sie es ein bisschen schwieriger gemacht und hier irgendwie noch Rust reingeschmissen.
Noch JavaScript reingeschmissen.
Ein bisschen mehr.
Aber das ist eindeutig Go.
Okay.
Ja.
Dank Ausschlussverfahren auch relativ einfach.
Auch wenn man die Sprachen immer wirklich verwendet.
Richtig Pascal.
Ruby kann es nicht sein.
Sieht überhaupt nicht aus wie Ruby.
Sieht doch überhaupt nicht aus wie PHP.
Dieses Ding hier.
Musik.
Was ist das nochmal?
Komm mir übelst bekannt vor.
23.
Ah, Soras Dome.
Genau.
Okay, also hier Pascal.
Eats.
Das ist jetzt tatsächlich ein bisschen ausgefallen.
Aber man kann es auch ganz gut durch Ausschlussverfahren erkennen.
Also das ist Brainfuck.
Verwendet kein Mensch.
Verwendet kein Mensch, aber es ist offensichtlich Brainfuck.
Nur für High-End-Brains geeignet.
Okay.
Das ist offensichtlich, Alter.
Das ist ein bisschen schwieriger.
Da kommen theoretisch mehrere Kandidaten in Betracht.
Aber es ist offensichtlich.
Also so eklig kann man das nur in einer der dort genannten Sprachen machen.
Die einzige Write-Only-Sprache.
Richtig.
Paul.
Next.
Hier musste ich echt überlegen.
Hier musste ich echt überlegen, was das ist.
Das ist schwierig.
Also es ist definitiv nicht XML und definitiv nicht Brainfuck.
Da sind wir uns glaube ich einig.
Aber ist es Scala oder ist es PHP?
Nicht so einfach.
Ich habe es auch durch Ausschlussverfahren gemacht.
Weil ich mir dachte, das sieht nicht nach PHP aus.
Aber ich könnte jetzt auch nicht so pauschal ausschließen, dass es PHP ist.
Deswegen würde ich sagen, es ist Scala.
Ich weiß, dass es Scala ist.
Weil ich habe das ja vorhin schon mal gemacht.
Aber das ist schwieriger gewesen.
Aber du hockweises Scala.
Gut.
Das solltet ihr alle aus meinen Streams kennen.
Was ist das?
Ich würde sagen, das ist eindeutig eine Inidatei, oder?
Bash.
Richtig.
Big Brain.
Ich schätze C-Sharp natürlich.
Noch mal für die etwas älteren unter uns.
Das ist kein Assembler.
Es ist die Sprache, die nicht tot zu kriegen ist.
Es ist Co-Wall.
Ein bisschen schwieriger.
Aber dank der Auswahl auch einfach.
Dank der Auswahl einfach.
Könnte schwierig sein.
Hätte man da so etwas wie Scala und Erlang und Gedöns und Haskell mit reingenommen,
dann wäre es schwierig gewesen.
Hainup hat recht, das ist F-Sharp.
Ich muss das F-Sharp sein.
Hätte man es schwieriger machen können.
Aber das ist ja nur die Aufwärm-Runde, das ist ja noch Eats.
Das andere, das hier, das ist richtig schwierig.
Next.
Ah ja, gut.
Erkennt man auch.
Was ist das?
Ist dank der Auswahl Ausschlussverfahren auch einfach.
C++ kann es nicht sein.
Sieht überhaupt nicht aus wie C++.
Wobei mich ehrlich gesagt nicht wundern würde,
wenn das nicht auch gültige C++-Sundags wäre in irgendeiner Art und Weise.
In C++ ist alles irgendwie gültig.
Aber es kann nicht C++ sein.
Ruby kann es auch nicht sein.
Und wie TypeScript sieht es auch nicht aus.
Also habe ich hier mal auf Haskell getippt.
So, letztes.
Was ist das?
Das wisst ihr alle.
Vor allem bei dieser Auswahl dabei.
Faith.
Ja, richtig.
C++, schon ewig kein Cod mehr gespielt.
Also richtig.
Modern Warfare Beta und ein bisschen Release mal außen vor gelassen.
Chat kennt sich aus hier.
Chat hat Ahnung.
So, das war jetzt die Auswahl-Runde.
Das war jetzt easy.
Das kann jeder.
Jetzt wird es schwierig.
Mit dem anderen Quiz kacke ich auch ab, muss ich sagen.
Weil das ist randomized.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt keine Ahnung, was kommt.
Das ist schwierig, zumal da 76 Programmiersprachen drin sind.
Und teilweise eine abgedrehter als die andere.
Okay, Play.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Was ist das?
Fuck, Alter.
Was?
Ich muss sagen, LoL-Code sieht irgendwie aus wie LOL.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
LoL-Code.
Also Brainfuck ist es nicht.
Aber was ist Bifunj?
Also was soll ich nehmen?
LoL-Code oder Bifunj?
LoL-Code, oder?
Wobei der High Noob kennt sich aus.
Der High Noob ist außerdem der High Noob-Sub.
Der muss sich auskennen.
Was soll ich nehmen?
LoL-Code oder Bifunj?
Bifunj.
Komm, Bifunj.
Wir nehmen Bifunj.
Bäm, richtig.
Excellent.
Okay, was ist das?
Das ist einfach.
Das ist Java.
Muss Java sein.
Eats.
Oder wie natürlich die coolen Leute sagen, Java.
Muss das sein.
Java.
Ach du Scheiße.
Ich habe nicht die leideste Ahnung, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ich muss mal das Bild verschieben.
Das ist voll im...
Wir brauchen die Chat-Power brauchen wir.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Also für Scala sind es nicht genug Klammern.
Prologue?
Für Erlang sind es auch nicht genug Klammern.
Das muss Prologue sein.
Ja.
Eats.
Wow, das wird ja immer eklicher.
Logtalk?
Smalltalk?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Logtalk?
Ich habe von der Sprache noch immer was gehört.
Was zum Teufel ist Logtalk?
Ja, Smalltalk und Scala sind definitiv relativ weit...
Na ja.
Scala ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich weit verbreitet.
Smalltalk nicht so wirklich.
Okay.
Smalltalk?
Logtalk.
Siehst du?
Lumix hatte recht.
Chat.
Chat hat es verkackt.
Next.
Das ist okay.
Das ist wieder einfach.
Vor allem erst mal Void-Sterlchen-Message muss alles Void-pointern.
Wobei mir nicht bewusst ist, dass man in C Putz verwenden kann.
Aber muss man, weil man kann ja auch Scan-Dings verwenden und so.
Aber das müsste eigentlich C sein, weil Void-Pointern, bin ich mir nicht sicher, wie sie in C++ ausschaut.
Und auch von dem her, die wollen das wahrscheinlich C.
So.
Alter.
Was soll das sein?
WTF?
Also Pascal ist es nicht.
C ist es auch nicht.
Also bleibt bloß ECL.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ECL ist.
Aber Ausschlussverfahren sagt mir, es ist ECL.
What?
Was?
Shakespeare?
Aha.
Yes.
Shakespeare.
Das war klar.
To be or not to be.
Excellent.
Nein.
Homespring.
Chat.
Alter.
Das kann man doch wissen.
Vertrauste einmal dem Chat, ey.
Okay.
Next.
Object, hello world, extents app.
Oh.
Extents klingt schon verdächtig mal nicht nach Prolog.
Oder?
Ne.
Ich tippe mal auf Scala.
Aber bei Scala hat es zu wenig Klammern.
O-Kammel?
Okay.
Wie spricht man das überhaupt aus?
Tja, Leute.
Beide Sprachen, in denen ich nicht viel Planen habe, ja.
Scala.
Ich tendiere, ich tendiere auch, wenn es zu wenig Klammern hat, doch irgendwie zu Scala,
ja.
Scala.
Bam.
Okay.
Das weiß ich jetzt.
Das weiß ich.
Was ist es?
AWK ist das.
Jawoll.
Eindeutig.
Kein Pearl.
Nee, ist kein Pearl, ist AWK.
Ähm.
Äh.
Okay, Ruby ist es nicht.
Fancy habe ich keine Ahnung.
Ich würde jetzt mal sagen Smalltalk.
Das ist Fancy.
Ja, super Fancy.
Aber brauchen wir mal Smalltalk Zeilen?
Ach, Moment.
Da sind keine Zeilennummer.
Das heißt, 3 times das da.
Das ist Fancy.
Okay, wenn die Leute sagen, das ist Fancy, dann glaube ich euch.
Hey, Chat.
Huge.
Oh, die wollen nicht ernsthaft wissen, was das für ein Dialekt ist, oder?
Sind die noch bei Sinn?
Keine Ahnung.
Kein Schimmer.
Ob das ladechkontakt...
Was weiß ich?
Keine Ahnung.
Alter, das ist fies.
Das ist echt fies.
Okay.
Ich sag jetzt einfach mal.
Nein.
Okay.
Smokersmoke.
Putz.
Ich würde ja eigentlich sagen, das ist Ruby.
Weil genau so würdest du das in Ruby auch machen.
Aber Ruby ist nicht zur Auswahl.
Für Erlang hat es zu wenig Klammern und für Lisp hat es definitiv zu wenig Klammern.
Also würde ich sagen, das ist TCL.
Ja.
Ähm.
Ist das Heske?
Idris?
Heske kann es...
Das sieht zu wenig funktional aus.
Aber wobei, ich hab... ey.
Mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir, es ist Heske.
Aber sicher bin ich, bin ich.
Es sieht ein bisschen funktional aus durch die Geschichte, dass du hier irgendwie sagst,
die Funktion irgendwie...
Bauchgefühl würde ich sagen, Heske.
Aber wissen tue ich es nicht.
Ah, fuck.
Der Hook hat recht.
Idris.
Was zum Teufel ist Idris eigentlich für eine Sprache?
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Deswegen.
Okay, next.
Ähm.
ClassDefHelloMessageFunctionDoIt.
DispHello.
Ich hab letztens mal in einem LXR Tutorial geguckt.
Ähm.
Und...
Ich...
...bilde mir ein.
Also LXR sah ähnlich aus.
Die haben auch Def benutzt.
Ähm.
Der Rest sah irgendwie anders aus.
Deswegen tendiere ich auch zu Matlab.
Ha!
Ein Leben noch, Leute.
Ein Leben noch.
Ähm.
Was haben wir hier?
Okay, das ist definitiv schon mal kein C++.
Das ist auch kein Java, das muss...
Nee, das ist kein C++.
Äh, es ist Valar, würde ich sagen.
Valar ist, ähm...
...vom GTK, dieser C-Sharp-Java-C++-Mischmasch.
Das müsste Valar sein.
Valar.
Ich schwör.
Oder?
Nee, es ist Valar.
Ziemlich sicher.
Ha!
Erwischt.
Oh je.
Okay.
Go ist es nicht.
Bauchgefühl sagt mir Smalltalk?
Aber was sagt der Chat?
Smalltalk.
Huge.
Okay, Smalltalk.
Äh, ja.
Ja.
Das ist definitiv kein C und es ist kein C++, das muss C-Sharp sein.
Da sind wir uns einig, ne?
Äh, Putz, Ruby.
Da ist Ruby.
Ähm.
What?
Okay.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Also Postscript?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich mein, Postscript ist zum Drucken.
Das kann schon Postscript sein.
Also Lisp ist es nicht.
Lisp ist es nicht.
Forst kenn ich nicht.
Also ich zendiere zu Postscript.
Postscript ist das, was du deinem Drucker schickst zum Drucken.
Ich sag mal Postscript.
Ha!
Eats.
Easy as fuck.
Okay, was haben wir jetzt als nächstes?
Foundation.h.
Das ist Objective-C, oder?
Das ist das Objective-C?
Das ist Objective-C.
Weil NS-Log.
NS klingt voll nach Objective-C.
Das Objective-C ist das.
Äh.
Das ist jetzt Elixir.
Das ist glaube ich jetzt Elixir.
Oder was sagt ihr?
Ich hab letztens ein Video darüber geguckt.
Das ist glaube ich jetzt Elixir.
Ah yes.
Ha!
Ach nee, jetzt schau wieder.
Mensch, hör mal auf mit dem Scheiß, ey.
Keine Ahnung.
Chat, ich vertraue euch, Chat.
Ich schenke mir was zu drehen.
Zwei Mal Lasix, einmal Kontext.
Ja, was machen wir jetzt?
Kontext.
Oh, The Hook, der hat vorhin schon mal richtig gelegen.
Außer ist er First-Time-Subscriber.
Oder Gründer-Abo.
Mensch, ja.
Hast du eigentlich Frau und Kind?
Nein.
Kontext.
Okay, ich glaub dir das jetzt mal.
Ha!
Print.
Okay, Go ist es nicht.
Genau.
Ich hab den Chat.
Also Go ist es nicht.
Java ist es auch nicht.
Es sieht nicht aus wie Java.
Also ist Gosu.
Ich hab keine Ahnung was zum Teufel.
Was Gosu für eine Sprache sein soll.
Das ist Gosu.
Ja, passt.
Ist das D?
Es ist nicht so wirklich C.
Es ist nicht so wirklich C-Sharp.
Also ist es D.
Ausschlussverfahren.
D ist irgendjemand, der mal der Meinung war,
er muss einen Nachfolger zu C++ oder einen C++-Nachfolger bauen.
Dann hat es D genannt.
So lange, bis man keine Lifes mehr hat.
Es ist...
Okay.
Ich nehm D.
Also es sieht nicht aus wie Erlang.
Finde ich.
Es sieht irgendwie nicht aus wie Erlang.
Es ist Force.
Ich will auch sagen, es ist Force.
Ich hab Force noch nie...
Force-Language.
1970.
Genauso sieht es aus.
Also es ist Force.
100...
Oh.
What the fuck?
Hello world, cake with chocolate sauce.
Was?
Nicht Google, ja.
Shakespeare, Brainfuck oder Chef?
Okay, das ist Chef.
Weil es ein Backrezept ist.
Wer denkt sich sowas aus?
Brainfuck.
Leute, Brainfuck, oder?
Sind wir uns einig.
Das muss Brainfuck sein.
Dart.
Es ist Dart.
Es kann kein Go sein.
Dafür stimmt die Funktionsdefinition nicht.
Es kann kein C sein.
Und die Funktion...
Es muss Dart sein.
Eats.
Wir hangeln uns hier ganz schön lang mit einem Lifelang.
Das ist Java?
Nee.
Groovy?
Groovy, groovy.
Chat, give energy.
Ist das groovy?
Java kann es nicht sein.
Da fehlen die Klammern um den Funktionsaufruf.
Es sieht überhaupt nicht aus wie Smalltalk.
Es muss groovy sein.
Aha.
A und dort rein.
Arghh.
Alter.
Komm ist ich immer mit dem Scheiß.
OK.
Der Chat ist mich so einig.
Das das der ist.
Pam.
Jawoll.
Nice.
Das könnte durchaus gültiges C sein, was wir hier sehen, kommt auf den Rest drumherum
an.
Dominik, wir erraten Programmiersprachen.
Man kriegt einen Ausschnitt aus dem Quelltext und da muss man erraten, was für eine Programmiersprache
ist.
Gibt es Text in C?
Ne, aber das könnte eine Funktion sein.
Also je nachdem wie das Programm drumherum aussieht, könnte das durchaus gültiges C
sein.
Aber ich tippe auch auf Processing, ich habe keine Ahnung was Processing ist.
Ja, Pokemon Song.
Ah, Hits.
Hey, Kay Stank Spy, Hi, Ken has standard IO, Visible High World, Kay Stank Spy, das
ist LoL Code, das muss LoL Code sein, das ist so blöde, das klingt schon so nach LoL
Code.
Yeah.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Pearl?
Pearl, Pearl.
Es muss Pascal sein?
Es ist Pascal?
Fortran?
Ne, Pascal Kansen?
Pascal, ne, Pascal wird der Kram großgeschrieben.
Das, aber Fortran?
Ah, nice.
Das ist ABAP, weil Cobol hat Zeilnummern.
Ich habe weder ABAP noch Cobol jeweils programmiert, ja.
Nicht ABAP, nicht, nicht, ok.
Sondern?
Achso, doch, das ist ABAP.
Das muss, müsste ABAP sein, nein, nein, es ist doch Cobol, hat Cobol nicht Zeilnummern?
Grip, Grip.
Darf ich einen Link posten?
Kommt darauf an, wohin?
Ok, stats, zeig mal, zeig mal, ob wir gut gewesen sind.
Nein, ich mein, wohin der Link zeigt, darauf kommt's an.
7500, Alter, was geht mit den Leuten ab, wir hatten 3000 und wir sind schon, Chat plus
mich.
Das speichere ich mir mal, das können wir öfters machen.
Das können wir öfters machen, ich speichere mir das mal, können wir ab und zu mal machen
im Stream.
Dankeschön Kyo-Kun, das wünschen wir dir auch, äh, fast.
Auf eine Seite, die dir zeigt, wie man ohne Java-Skript IP-Tracking jetzt die User footprinten
kann.
Kannst du mal posten, ja, können wir uns mal angucken.
So, oh ne, ready to start page, so wir gucken uns jetzt mal ein nice Video, das hab ich
vor einer Weile schon mir angeschaut und fand ich richtig gut gemacht.
Geht halt, 47 Minuten, geht um irgendwelche Speed.
Aha, interessant.
Hi, das ist interessant, ok, wirklich Java-Skript blocken bringt nichts.
Sehr interessant, ja.
Hehehe, machen gar nichts, oder?
Die machen wahrscheinlich das anhand meiner Request auf dem Server irgendwie fest, oder
ne?
Das ist wahrscheinlich gar nichts kleinzeitiges.
Das ist hardcoded, oder?
Das ist einfach hardcoded.
Das ist, äh, G-Bait.
Ja, entweder ist das bei IP, oder, oder bei, oder, ne, hardcoded ist es schonmal nicht.
Der Link scheint nicht so, scheint nicht, nicht gut.
Das muss irgendeine Geschichte sein, äh, was die anhand vom Request festmachen.
Das ist aber gut gemacht, aha, ok, das ist, das ist aber gut, ja.
Es gibt so unglaublich viele Varianten, mittlerweile User zu tracken, aber es ist gut, huge brain.
Ok, jetzt gucken wir uns mal das Video zu, ups nein, äh, das Video zu den Mario Kart
Rekorden an.
Alter, ich abgratze jetzt.
Is it impossible to upload a mathematically impossible level in Mario Maker?
Das interessiert mich jetzt, das müssen wir jetzt gucken.
Das müssen wir jetzt gucken.
Mal gucken, ich mein, ich spiel zwar kein Mario Maker, aber das klingt nach huge brain
content.
Ok, so about two weeks ago I thought it would be fun to theorycraft the strongest and most
secure combination log possible in Super Mario Maker 2.
There never really was a point to this in the first Mario Maker, since everyone was able
to download each course and therefore everyone was able to take a look at the combination.
But since Nintendo sadly decided that editing downloaded courses is no longer a thing in
Mario Maker 2, that also means that, at least in theory, it should be possible to upload
a combination log stage that is so secure that it becomes cryptographically impossible.
Ah, yes, alles klar Leute.
Ah.
I sat down and naively started to scribble together a couple of different designs for
logs.
Ah, yes.
Not knowing.
Excellent.
So, over the last two weeks I spent way, way, way too much time trying to come up with
the absolute perfect combination log in Super Mario Maker 2.
It honestly almost drove me insane.
So today we are going to take a look back at this journey, we will not only succeed in
building a log that is mathematically impossible to beat, but we will also fail miserably at
trying to upload a truly impossible stage.
So you ready?
Let's do this!
Ich check so überhaupt nicht warum und weshalb, aber weil's geht denke ich mal, ne?
Einfach nur weil's möglich ist.
Alright, so before we hop into Mario Maker and try to theorycraft the perfect log, we
first quickly have to talk about how combination logs function in the first place.
So how do logs work?
The probably easiest way to think of the safety of a combination log is to assume that each
log has a certain numerical safety.
The interesting thing here is that this number is defined by two things, the base of the
log and its length.
A standard bicycle log for example often contains a number of four numbers between zero to nine.
So each spot in the log is one out of ten different numbers.
We are going to call this number...
Der redet so big brain language, das ist einfach normale Leute, die wir nicht verstehen.
Also gebt ihr gar keine Mühe.
Also was der uns gerade glaub ich versucht zu erklären ist, was ein Schloss sicher macht
beziehungsweise was eine Schlüsselkombination sicher macht.
Und das erste ist natürlich wie viele Varianten du hast, also beim Passwort wie viele Varianten
du hast, also wie viele verschiedene Zeichen du hast und dann wie lang das ganze ist.
Ist im Prinzip bei einem Schloss jetzt das gleiche.
Genau, Base ist im Prinzip was du für verschiedene Zeichen hast, also in dem Fall hast du bei
einem normalen Schloss wo du so Drehrädchen dran hast, null bis neun, hast du null bis
neun also zehn verschiedene mögliche Zeichen pro Stelle und das ganze ist vier Stellen
lang.
Das ist so ein Standard Schloss was beispielsweise an so einem Koffer oder so ein kleines Zahlenschloss
das heißt du hast zehntausend Varianten die man durchprobieren muss.
Das ist nicht viel, allerdings von Hand durchzuprobieren dauert ein bisschen.
Passwort mäßig ist es, er baut ein Zahlenschloss in Mario Maker, ich glaube das hat er vor,
er möchte einen Schloss in Mario Maker bauen wo nur er die Kombination kann und es so unwahrscheinlich
ist dass man es errät, dass man das Level nicht lösen kann.
Also, huge brain, ja, es baut Passwort dann übrigens auch so ne, wo wir gerade dabei
sind, es baut Passwort dann auch so, das wichtigste ist eigentlich dass das Passwort lang ist.
Deswegen ist es fragwürdig, dass so viele Webseiten immer noch, immer noch quasi erzwingen
dass da ein Sonderzeichen, Groß- und Kleinschreibung, eine Zahl und sowas drin sein muss, man sollte
einfach sagen ab einer gewissen Länge ist alles erlaubt, weil es ist einfach easy zu
merken wenn man jetzt ein Passwort macht so nach dem Motto, nach dem Motto, mein cute
chat Twitch ist beste, das ist so ein langes Passwort da kommt keine Sau drauf und das
kannst du auch nicht einfach mal so ausblenden, auch wenn es normale Wörter sind und das
ist dann schon ziemlich sicher, wohingegen wenn ich jetzt gezwungen werde das Sonderzeichen
rein zu machen und Zahlen und sonst was, dann kann ich mir den Kram nicht mehr merken.
Ja wenn du 0 dranhängst, ja das ist relativ einfach auszurechnen, vor allem wenn du 0
bis 10 an Zeichen hast, da hängst du einfach das da in Nullen hinten dran und gut ist,
guck bam, mach doch als Leerzeichen ein Dollar, kannst du machen ja, wenn du das merken kannst,
ja das stimmt, das war passwort, dann genau das gleiche.
Also ich will jetzt nicht hier vorgeben, dass ich verstehe was da gerade passiert, aber
ich finde es trotzdem interessant, was erwartet, weil ich habe keine Ahnung von den Mario Maker
Mechanics.
Ah big brain!
believably easy to reverse engineer the code, just by counting how many brave goombas bravely
died before there is no more brave goombas to cowardly kill.
We'll talk about all the problems of making a lock unreverse engineerable in a second,
but for now let's focus on the base and its length.
See when building this lock I made a really stupid mistake.
I focused on building a lock in our lame, standard and boring decimal numerical base
10 system.
While there is absolutely no reason to do so in a mushroom kingdom.
There is no benefit if a lock has a base of 10, all it does is heavily limiting us with
the entity limit.
What we need is a much more creative way to represent the lock.
Think about the lottery, as an example a standard lottery often wants us to get 6 key numbers
between 0 and 47.
That's nothing else than trying to brute force a combination lock base 48 with a length
of 6.
We just make the base really high, so that it becomes counterintuitive how many different
options a lottery lock actually has.
For a perfect mario maker lock, we should basically say, opposite approach, we should
try to minimize how many different entities we need per lock cell and focus on getting
the lock as long as possible within the 100 entity limit.
So the first idea I had was just to build a really long lock using binary numbers.
Binary means that each lock cell only has exactly two inputs.
Either no question block didn't get triggered or triggering the question block it was.
If we found a way to just combine 40 of such cells into a single lock, then we would already
have more than 1 trillion different combinations, while each additional cell would grow this
number exponentially.
Hooray.
So here's the first prototype.
Here's the question block here, represents a single digit and has two inputs.
Triggered and not triggered.
If you trigger a question block, the blaster jumps upwards.
The blasters have two different height levels.
The idea here is that we only get a flat surface at the top if all blasters are at the correct
spot.
If a blaster that needs to get triggered doesn't get triggered, then there is a gap at the
top.
So if a blaster that should not get triggered gets triggered however, then this blaster
is one spot too high.
Super simple stuff.
The way we reach this...
Super simple?
Easy!
Also Leute.
Leute.
Super simple, oder?
Easy as f**k.
Kann man echt nix sagen.
Also wer da noch Fragen hat, der ist wirklich, der sollte uninstallen.
Easy as f**k.
A block that slowly transports a cannon to an enemy at the far left.
Only if the top is a straight line and therefore all inputs were entered correctly, the cannon
reaches the enemy, crushes it and rewards us with a key in the process.
Hooray!
Sadly this design has several problems.
First we have to put the blasters onto global ground, because otherwise they despawn while
we enter the combination.
Second, we also have to put global ground at the top so that the cannon does not despawn
while the lock gets red, since icicles aren't global ground anymore.
We no longer have a global ground option that does not count towards the enemy limit, so
we can only build this lock with a length of a bit over 40, that's slightly better than
our previous design, but still pretty meh.
Luckily, I just lied to you when I said that there are no more global ground options that
do not count towards the entity limit, because there is something in the game that counts
towards the block limit while also being global ground.
Something super weird.
Cloud blocks in the 3D world style.
Yep, I know that it is super weird, but normal cloud blocks in 3D world act as global ground.
This means that if we build a lock like this in 3D world, we do not have to use platforms
on tracks as global ground anymore.
Here is what such a lock looks like.
This lock has a length of 64 at the base of 2.
This means that this super simple lock is able to store about 18 quintillion numbers.
18 quintillions are a billion billions.
That's why the secure lock that we got there.
Sadly, it doesn't really work for several reasons.
First, the springs that we spawn to get the blasters upwards unfortunately also land on
global ground, which means that we fill the ELB at some point.
Leute, ich hab keine Ahnung was passiert, ich blicke nicht mehr durch, aber ich steh trotzdem
nice.
So we need to find a better way to input numbers as well as we need to find a better way to
read the state of the lock.
So the best and cheapest way to read the lock is just to have mario escort an enemy to the
other side.
That's not the problem.
The real problem is how to do the inputs in such a way that we do not require global ground
or any other additional entities.
And this ladies and gentlemen is where stuff gets a bit insane.
So as it turns out we can ignore global ground entirely if we use spawn blocking and an escort
version to read the lock.
Check this out.
Here we input our code by breaking the brick blocks at the bottom.
Each broken brick block means we entered a 1 into our lock.
Ne, das Video ist neu.
Das ist neu.
Das ist vom 13.
Or da noch ein neueres.
At the top we have red dotted line blocks and here's the catch.
Those red dotted line blocks spawn block bullet blasters.
Bullet blasters can't spawn while there is a red block occupying their home space.
But as soon as a two state block gets flipped, they are suddenly able to spawn again.
The basic idea here is the same as before.
Each blaster has one.
Ja, nitro express 10.000 Kombination ist zu low.
The correct combination provides a bled surface for an enemy to fall through.
We brauchen 75 Billiarden.
The input either makes the enemy fall down or blocks the path forward entirely.
This only requires a single enemy that carries a key and a single blaster per lock cell, since
we can put the on-off block into a different sub-world.
This lock can be built with a length of 99, the only entity space that isn't used by
lock cells.
Hattest du mal PXE in einem LXC laufen?
Ne.
Aber sollte doch kein Problem sein, PXE-Sofer im LXC laufen zu lassen und sollte überhaupt
kein Unterschied sein zu einem PXE-Sofer im normalen System laufen lassen.
Du musst halt gucken, dass ein Netzwerk gebridged ist, dass die ganzen Broadcast-Geschichten
ankommen.
Ah, so, so machen wir das.
So, so machen wir das.
Aber wir sind noch nicht fertig, denn obwohl es nicht möglich ist, die Länge des Locks
zu verbessern, ist es tatsächlich möglich, das Base-Value zu verbessern.
Siehst du, seit wir jetzt mit Spawn-Blocking arbeiten, gibt es keinen Grund für uns, das
in Binary zu bauen.
Wir können tatsächlich viele Brickblocks pro Cell als Artikel einzupassen, da der Lock
für Mario noch invisible sein muss, während es schwarz wird.
Die maximale Höhe der Brickblocks ist 8, 8 Brickblocks gibt uns eine Base 9, da 0 auch
eine Input-Option ist.
Hier ist wie das funktioniert.
Es gibt nur einen Weg für den Blaster, um genau die richtige Höhe zu haben, und das ist,
wenn die richtige Menge von Brickblocks zerstört wurde.
Dieser Blaster z.B.
Spawnt nur, wenn 7 Block zerstört werden.
Wenn ein kleinerer 7 in den Block kommt, dann bleibt immer ein Brickblock, der den Blaster
spawnen lässt.
Also du musst quasi, nur wenn du die richtige Anzahl Blöcke, Krowns, Stomps, Pawnest, was
auch immer, dann spawnt der Blaster und durch den Blaster geht es, ach du Scheiße, Alter.
Ja, viel Spaß.
Viel Spaß.
Alter.
So muss das sein.
Nach 2 Sekunden findest du die richtige Kombination, theoretisch möglich, aber sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Ich hab nicht mal Mario Maker 2, ich kann das nicht mal ausprobieren.
Ja gut, diese Sachen kann man ja auch auf Passwörter anwenden, wo dann so Rechnungen
rauskommen, so irgendwie, wenn alle Rechner der Welt 24 Stunden blablabla irgendwie rechnen
würden, dann wären die nicht fertig vor dem Ende des Universums, so nach dem Motto.
Das ist halt voll übertrieben so, die Zahl ist definitiv groß genug, dass sie nicht
einfach erraten wird.
Man kann doch garantiert Mario Maker Level runterladen und dann sich irgendwie auf ne
SD-Karte oder so angucken, irgendwie so Mario Maker Level Decompiler oder so, gibt es doch
100% schon.
Ja, Moment, Herz93, es geht offiziell nicht, nicht in Mario Maker, aber es gibt doch bestimmt
irgendeine Möglichkeit, Mario Maker Level herunterzuladen.
WTF die Leute, Alter.
So, hier wir haben es, an impossible to guess lock, that sadly can be cheated by modding.
And this is the end of the video, except as it turns out, it actually surprisingly isn't,
so let me share a little story with you.
So a couple of weeks ago a US gamer turned on a quickmail telling me that he was thinking
about writing a quick story about passcode levels in Super Mario Maker 2 and whether
I'd be willing to answer him a couple of questions, and I was like sure, why not.
And then, then I started to wonder, what is actually the most secure combination lock.
So I sat down and started to tinker around with it, and this is what caused this whole
madness.
So I took our US gamer journalist a while to get back to me, and once he replied I actually
was already half finished with this video.
So here's where this gets interesting, because the first question he asked me was
something along the lines of, do you think vtrek's passcode level is optimally designed,
or do you think that his design can still be improved?
And I was like, which vtrek design again?
So as it turns out I wasn't the only one wasting way too much time of my life trying
to get a meaningless number as high as possible, because as it turns out the legendary mario
maker creator vtrek was working on this as well, and as it turns out he found a way to
build a combination lock that is much, much, much more secure than the design we just
saw in this video, so I'm not going to spoil how he did it, because he made an amazing and
awesome combination lock, so I hope you enjoyed it, don't forget to leave me a thumbs up and
maybe feel especially combinational today, and don't forget to hit the subscribe button
as well.
I hope that all of you have a wonderful day and to see you soon.
Goodbye.
WTF.
Das ist ja hart.
Aber wo man wieder schön dran sieht, sobald was geht, wirds gemacht.
Eigentlich könnte man Mario Maker schon in diese Liste aufnehmen, so nach dem Motto errate
die Programmiersprache.
Echtig.
Grasershit.
ETF.
Oh man.
Wie lange sind wir denn eigentlich schon on?
Leute, ich muss mal aufs Klo.
Ich muss mal aufs Klo, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Ich bin gleich wieder am Start, kurz afk.
Ich bin gleich wieder aufs Klo, ich bin gleich wieder am Start, kurz afk.